Gold with his 17 millions was one of the colossal failures of our time.
He was a purely selfish man. His greed consumed his charity.
He was like death and hell gathering and all giving back nothing.
These were words spoken at a sermon shortly after Jay Gould's death.
And they are representative of what much of the American public thought about
the rich industrialist.
He was regarded as one of the worst examples of the robber Baron suit thrived
during the economic boom of America's gilded age gold would become one of the
richest men in the country,
and he didn't care who he had to crush to achieve his goals.
Many of the methods Gould employed would simply be illegal today,
but even back then,
they were enough to make and hated by his fellow businessmen.
But there was another group who hated him even more.
The press Gould operated during the rise of yellow journalism pioneered by
Joseph Pulitzer and William Randolph Hearst,
then newspapers focused on scandals and sensationalism to sell copies a
technique which works wonders.
Some historians who are trying to rehabilitate Jay Gould's image argue that he
was a favorite whipping by of the press, particularly Pulitzer's New York world,
which he actually purchased from gold in 1883.
They believe that the industrialists negative reputation was mainly a creation
of the media ruins.
That gold was not especially more or less ruthless than all of the other
business magnates of his time. We'll let you decide that for yourself though.
We'll just present a story and you can draw your own conclusions regarding the
quintessential robber Baron Jay Gould.
[Inaudible].
Jason J. Gould was born on may the 27th, 1836 in Roxbury, New York,
the son of John burgles and Mary Moore.
He was descended from Scottish immigrants and his new English Puritans his great
grandfather on his mother's side.
John Moore came to America in 1772 and founded the small town of
Morrisville known today as grand Gorge. His son,
John Taylor Moore became an influential politician in New York who served as
state Senator and as a member of the New York state assembly, multiple times,
by the time Jay gold was born, most of that power and wealth had diminished.
His parents were just quiet farmers and it was expected that Jay would follow in
his father's footsteps. However, he had no interest in farming.
So instead he began working various odd jobs after receiving a basic education
at the school in Hobart,
New York first Gould worked at his father's store and in his free time taught
himself surveying.
He was good enough that he turns this into his new profession for a few years
after he surveyed several of the Southern counties of New York Gould wrote and
published a book when he was only 19 years old,
titled history of Delaware County and border Wars of New York afterwards,
Gould was employed by blacksmith shop,
where he learns about a different trade that will become his first true business
leather tanning. During the 1850s, he used the money.
He had saved up to open a tannery in Pennsylvania and an areas that would later
become the town of Gouldsborough in his own neck.
He did this in partnership with a man named Zanuck Pratt 45 years older than
ghouls, perhaps once operated the largest tannery in the world in the Catskill
mountains. However, as the advanced in age,
he preferred instead to finance multiple smaller tanneries and let his younger
partners do the hard work. That is also what he did with gold.
Although their partnership only lasted for a few years before proffer Todd for
goods and is up and coming coworker bought out his shares.
Yeah.
Early on, Jay Gould concluded that any serious money would be made in New York.
Therefore, as soon as he made some significant cash from his tannery,
he moved to the city and began speculating on the stock market.
But this time gold also partnered with a leather merchant named Charles lib,
but their joint venture ended on considerably worse terms than with Pratt gold
was a risk taker. They used the money that he received from investors,
primarily lib to try and corner the hide market. However,
then came the panic of 1857, a financial crash,
which was greatly exacerbated in the United States by the sinking of the SS
central America, a ship carrying a giant shipment of gold from California.
Banks took heavy losses and investments went bottom up,
Liam lost everything and ended up committing suicide.
And the decades that followed the stories that went around was that gold
intentionally drove his partner into poverty and death by making dangerous
transactions so that he would then be able to buy out all of his properties for
cheap.
This is a good example of the kind of tales that were propagated about Google in
his own time detailing the viciousness of his business dealings,
but there was really little evidence to back them up in this particular case,
what Google did was certainly risky,
but he could hardly be blamed for the panic of 1857. Furthermore,
more had been documented that Charles Lee had suffered from mental problems,
such as depression and severe paranoia,
which undoubtedly contributed to his suicide. That being said,
Gould was certainly no saints by any stretch of the imagination.
Often Liam's death.
There was a dispute over ownership of the tannery and Goldsboro between Jay
Gould and another one of his investors,
layups brother-in-law David Williams and leave this dispute lasted for 10 years.
And eventually the courts ruled in Lee's favor. By that point,
Gould was already a very rich man and the tannery wasn't worth much anyway.
So he sold his interest to the Lee family for a nominal fee.
It just goes to show the kind of man the good was he was willing to fight tooth
and nail for years for something that he didn't even care about,
just so that he wasn't the one on the losing side
Done with the tanning business.
Gold became a fully fledged stockbroker on wall street. He had a knack for this,
but he also used every advantage at his disposal to manipulate the market to his
advantage. This included tactics, which although unethical were illegal,
such as short-selling, but he was also alleged to have bribed politicians,
judges,
and anyone else necessary in order to pass favorable legislation and shut down
laws that worked against him. However,
he truly emerged as one of the country's leading industrialists.
When he began getting involved in railroads,
he first dipped his toes into these waters in 1857, right after the panic,
as the stocks plunge,
the Rutlands and Washington railroads that connected Rutlands of the monster
Eagle bridge New York was on the brink of bankruptcy.
The opportunity presented itself for gold to purchase a controlling interest in
the railway for 10 cents on the dollar afterwards, he had it repaired.
And as the railroad managed to weather, the financial storm of 1857,
it then became commercially successful. Then in just a couple of years,
gold sold it for a large profit. This was a nice start,
but it mainly serve to show the businessmen that a lot of money could be made in
railroads.
He then set a science a lot higher on the Erie railroad triggering a conflict
between four of America's richest men known as the Arie war.
The Erie railroad was a very appealing target for anyone looking to invest.
It was not only one of the longest railways in the country,
but it also has a prime location.
As it crossed New York state from New York city to Buffalo, despite this,
it experienced financial troubles during the 1850s due to pull managements and
large building costs and came Daniel drew one of the protagonists of the Aerie
war. He was a financier who originally made his money from cattle,
but how does fingers in many lucrative pies?
He loans the struggling railroad $2 million,
which ends in a place on the board of directors. Of course,
this would have been only the beginning for drew.
Was he fully intended to gain a controlling interest of the railroad,
but he soon discovered that he had very stiff competition from Cornelius
Vanderbilt, the richest man in America and someone we've already covered here on
biographics. If you want to check his video out anyway, three,
realize that he had little hope of going against Vanderbilt alone.
So he found two partners.
They were Jay Gould and another stockbroker named diamond.
Jim James Fisk together, the three of them conspired to trick Vanderbilt.
Since they knew that his intention was to corner the market and buy all of the
available stock and the eerie railroad, they watered it down,
meaning that they kept issuing additional stock and artificially inflating its
value. This wasn't legal even back then. And in 1868,
the three financier's that the flee New York city after a judge ended their
activity and cited the entire board of directors of the area railroad to appear
in court in a truly bizarre moments that the press ate up.
The trio barricaded themselves in a New Jersey hotel in Todd bodyguards to
protect the entrances around the clock.
All they needed was to stall for time is they had an ACE up their sleeves.
It was their connection to Tammany hall, the highly corrupt,
highly influential democratic party political machine ruled by William boss,
Tweed. He arranged for favorable legislation,
which legalized their issue of stock in exchange for a director's position on
the airy railroad.
And certainly quite a lot of generous donations, journalist,
Gustavo as Meyers who covered the scandal.
Rotes how the New York politicians were equally accepting bribes from both
groups and siding with the one paid the most writing members of the legislature.
Impassively took money from both parties.
Gould personally appeared at Albany with a central containing $500,000 in
greenbacks, which were rapidly distributed.
One Senator as was disclosed by an investigating committee,
accepted $75,000 from Vanderbilt and then a hundred thousand dollars from Gould
captured both sons and voted with the dominant gold forces.
Exactly how the Erie war resolved itself is unclear.
Eventually Vanderbilt and drew called a meeting.
And it's reached an understanding with unknown terms. Vanderbilt backs off the,
got the Erie railroad to buy backs,
the watered down stocks that he had purchased.
And just to show that there is truly no honor among thieves,
Fisk and gold turned on very once. Vanderbilt was out of the picture in 1870,
they again manipulated the stocks in such a way that their former partner lost
money. It was data greatly affected by another financial crisis in 1873.
And by 1876,
he had been forced into retirement after having to declare bankruptcy.
Daniel drew died in 1879, completely penniless.
The second of Gold's partners to meet such a fate. Meanwhile,
James Fisk had been murdered in 1872.
While boss Tweed was imprisoned on multiple corruption charges as for Gould
himself.
He was also forced apart with the Erie railroad against his wishes in a way that
nobody saw coming.
And it wasn't another wealthy industrialist who got the best of G ghouls.
It wasn't the authorities either.
It was a con man who suckered gold out of a million dollars and almost caused
Minnesota to invade Canada. His real name is lost to history,
but he was known as Lord Gordon Gordon,
his name scam involved portraying himself as a Scottish nobleman and obtaining
goods and services on credit. Of course,
eventually everybody called him the debt and the fraud was discovered.
So this scheme required a constant change of scenery around 1817.
Lord Gordon Gordon had been exposed as a fake in London.
So he sought out greener pastures in America.
He arrived in Minnesota where he posed as a Lord looking to invest lots of
money, even deposited around $40,000.
All the money left over from his previous swindles and a local bank.
This was enough to convince everyone that he was legit and he soon made the
acquaintance of officials from the Northern Pacific railroad who were looking
for investors. They wines and Dines, Lord Gordon sparing,
no expense in trying to persuade him to purchase the railroad land.
Eventually he agreed to that DUNS,
but said that he needed to travel to New York first to make arrangements for the
money transfer.
He left Minnesota never intending to return again with the people he called and
smiling and waving goodbye.
Gordon Gordon made an immediate splash in New York.
He booked a lavish penthouse for himself and did letters of introduction from
his former partners in Minnesota.
So he quickly injected himself into the upper crust of society,
through discussions with Horace Greeley,
the founder and editor of the New York Tribune Gordon discovered that there was
a power struggle going on for control of the Erie railroad.
Somehow the Scottish Lord managed to convince greedy that he owned tens of
thousands of stocks in that railroad,
his European associates in that the word spread. And soon enough,
he received a visit from Jay Gould.
The American industrialist was already working on his own scheme to gain control
of the railroad.
And the last thing he needed was to have a European consortium come in and pull
the rug from underneath him. He wanted to strike a deal with golden pool,
their resources together Gould's takes control of the company and the Scottish
nobleman names. The directors of his choosing to look after his interests,
Lord Gordon pretended to be intrigued, but also reluctance.
Why would he trust Jay ghouls? He asked for a guarantee,
a million dollars and stocks and cash, not dispense,
but to keep as a sign of good faith until that business was concluded,
Gould immediately accepted.
And it took him a while to realize that he had been cons.
When Gordon began cashing in the stocks that theoretically,
he said he wouldn't touch. He sued Gordon, took him to trial in March, 1873.
He also contacted the Scottish aristocrats, alleged associates in Europe,
who all said that, that never heard of this Lord Gordon Gordon.
It would have been an easy conviction,
but Gordon fled to Canada before being arrested. That was bad for Gould.
Besides the money he had lost from the stocks Gordon had cashed in.
He lost even more. Once word got out about the swing door,
causing the value of the Erie railroad stocks to go down.
But he wasn't the only one. He wanted to get his hands on Lord Gordon,
because his targets from Minnesota also heard of the con man escaping across the
border. It is uncertain exactly what role goals played and what happened next.
But a group of prominent Minnesotans went to Canada and kidnaps Nord Gordon
Gordon, hoping to bring him back to the States. However,
they were caught at the border arrested and held without bail, Minnesota,
governor Horace,
Austin was ready to raise a militia and invade Canada in order to get his men
released. It took intervention from us,
president Ulysses S grant and Canadian prime minister, John MacDonald,
to avoid an international incident.
Once the extent of Gordon's crimes were established,
the Canadian government degree do extradite him,
but the con man committed suicide before this could happen. As for Jay ghouls,
his connection to Lord Gordon Gordon had been a disaster ignoring the money he
caused personally,
the damage that he caused to the stock of the Erie railroad gave us opponents on
the board of directors, all the Ana,
they needed to force him out of the company. After all the years, the bribes,
the betrayals,
none of the participants in the Arie war got to enjoy the prize that,
that fought so hard.
[Inaudible].
Gold lost the Erie railroad. He did not abandon the industry altogether.
Instead he looked for new opportunities out West and still managed to amass,
quite a large railroad empire for himself.
He started by buying the union Pacific,
which had been hurt dramatically by the panic of 1873.
He then purchased a few other railways.
You stock had plummeted and made repairs and improvements on all of them.
Once the economy began to recover, he sold his stock for large profits.
Besides transportation gold also got involved in communications,
particularly Telegraph companies in 1875.
He took over the Atlantic and Pacific Telegraph company.
One of the main competitors to Western union.
He then a rate war with all the other major companies,
eventually selling a and P to Western union for another nice profit.
This is all well and good,
but it doesn't really have the scandal and controversies that we've come to
expect from Gould's business ventures.
For that we have to travel into the past just a bit to 1869 back when he was
still partnered with James Fisk for all their shady wheelings and dealings.
The two enacted a scheme to try and corner the gold market that involved the
president of the United States himself and shook the foundations of the American
economy. It became known as black Friday, the original black Friday, a term,
which has since been used to refer to numerous disastrous events that occur on
this day of the week.
Golden Fisk had made the acquaintance of a man named Abel Corbett.
He was a small time financier and speculator,
but he also happens to be married to Virginia Grant sister,
president Ulysses S grant through him,
the doing that the presidents and entered his confidence back to then the
country was still shaky.
Following the civil war as part of its plan to help stabilize the dollar to
boost the economy.
Grants enacted a policy where the us treasury would regularly sell gold at a
discount for dollars. During this time,
golden Fisk had been buying quite a lot of gold on the open market,
but of course,
as long as it was available at a discount to the value of their investment would
stay low. What they needed was for the government to stop selling gold.
So there'd be a bigger demand for it.
After being introduced by Corbin golden Fisk casually brought up the subject of
gold with president grounds at various social gatherings.
They both argued against the government set of gold.
And of course they were backed by Abel Corban.
They also had a man on the inside then general Daniel Butterfield who was
assistant treasurer and informs them when the government was getting ready to
sell all the pieces were in place to make a killing on the gold market.
Golden Fisk, amassed, mass, large supply of gold.
And when the treasury stopped selling,
they just sat back and watched the value of their investment.
Go through the roof. Of course,
they intended to unload it right before the treasury started selling against and
maximize their profits. But that plan backfired.
Eventually grant realized he had been swindled and ordered the immediate sale of
$4 million in gold.
This caused the value of the precious metal diplomas plunging the entire stock
market into chaos. This happens on September the 24th, 1869, a date,
which became known as black Friday,
many speculators and investors were ruins that day.
But golden Fisk made out nicely.
They heard of Grant's plan from Butterfields and had time to sell off most of
their gold reserves. They also avoided any legal repercussions,
partly because they were smart in how they carried out their scheme.
But mainly because they were tried in New York where they were protected by
friendly judges who were associates of boss, Tweed
Talked about Jay Gould's private life so far because there was nothing
spectacular. As I mentioned, he married Helen J. Miller in 1863,
when they were both in their mid twenties,
they had six children together who did what you would expect for that time
period.
The men became businessmen and investors like their father and the women became
socialites and philanthropists gold contracted in 1892.
What we today called tuberculosis. And he died on December. The second age,
56, his wealth was placed at around $72 million at the time of his death.
Although more recent estimates claimed that it was closer to a hundred million
dollars, but that Gould intentionally downplayed as wealth for tax purposes.
As you might expect, there weren't many kind words set about Jay Gould.
After he died with one pastor decrying him, the human incarnation of avarice,
a thief in the night stalking his fellow man, the newspapers were even harsher.
Although many did concede that gold had tremendous business acumen.
Nowadays historians look upon his legacy a bit more favorably and argue that
while Jay Gould was no philanthropist,
he did do some good particularly improving the infrastructure of the country's
railroad network. So I really hope you found the video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe and as always, thank you for watching.